let's do an example on the performing
translations exercise use the translate
tool to find the image of triangle WI n
for a translation of six units positive
six units in the X direction and
negative three units in the Y Direction
all right so we want to go positive six
units in the X direction and negative
three units in the Y direction all right
so I click on the translate tool click
on the translate tool and I want to go
so I want to go positive six units in
the X Direction so I could pick any
point and go six to the right and
everything else is going to come with it
so one two three four five six so I did
that part I translated positive six
units in the x direction and negative
three units in the Y direction so
everything is to go down by three one
two three and notice I focused on point
and this is its image now or the image
of point and this whole triangle is the
image of this entire triangle the
triangle Wyn after the transformation
but you see that every point shifted six
to the right six to the right and three
down this point over here six to the
right would take you let's see it said
it's at one and a half right now its
x-coordinate is one and a half it's new
x-coordinate is seven and a half so its
x-coordinate increased by six and it's
old y-coordinate or the original
y-coordinate was six and now in the
image the corresponding y coordinate is
3 so it has we have shifted it down
three so we've seen that that's happened
to every point here and we're done